[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
I'm sure it's just a coincidence that
you're playing something from the Cure
as we're trying to cure what ails
college football that's exactly what I
was thinking thank you Mark thank you we
were just reminiscing about the Big East
remember obviously you do if you're a
sports fan Big East best basketball
conference ever and then what dismantled
the Big East all of these schools well
Connecticut you know you want to get
that football money
and and then all of a sudden you're
looking at you know Georgetown doesn't
play football and Villanova doesn't play
football you had these biggie schools St
John's doesn't play football you had the
perfect model for hey this is a
basketball conference you want to play
other sports in other conferences go get
them and then I saw Dan Wetzel from
Yahoo sports he wrote about how about
Football Conference can we do that
because other school you know Notre Dame
will play independent but they're going
to play basketball in the ACC but they
may play a couple of ACC schools like
why do we have to do this we thought
we'd bring in Dan Wessel Yahoo sports
columnist New York Times best-selling
author okay
how do we go about this that it seems
logical that you have a football
conference and then maybe you have
basketball conferences why can't we do
this
okay well the first thing you got to
remember about College athletics no one
is in charge there isn't no one driving
this boat
there's no Roger Goodell there's no Adam
Silver there is an NCAA president but
that's just a figurehead there are a
whole bunch of fiefdoms so even a good
idea that literally everyone agrees
would make sense no one thinks Rutgers
should be playing Oregon in volleyball
nobody thinks that yet here we are you
mentioned the biggest very interesting
example of this university Connecticut
four national titles while they're in
the Big East then they go play in the
AAC because of football they're trying
to find a home for football they're
still playing good basketball teams
Houston Memphis things like that but
they're no longer in the Big East and
they lose touch with the recruits in
their area New York and all that they
give up the AAC return back for
basketball in in the Big East who's your
National Champion Connecticut it just
makes sense sometimes for certain
leagues let alone all of your Olympic
sports there's no uh hockey does this
right Hockey East has teams from the ace
ACC the Big East the Atlantic 10. they
have uh FC FB uh FCS like one double A
teams they have division two teams it's
okay it works because it's just a hockey
league nobody really is paying attention
but for all these other ones we just
can't do it because no one can go guys
what are we doing here
let me give you total autonomy
where do you start
for this for this problem yeah because
there's a lot there's a lot there's a
lot of checklist let me just do yeah
let's just stay with football
realignment just football schools yeah I
would actually probably create
um some kind of like uh Regional there's
actually one out west called the
mountain pack
um that handles sort of these excess
sports that not everyone does beach
volleyball water polo I would probably
create some like Regional
six or seven Regional kind of umbrellas
that handle those areas so let's take
the state of Texas right you pretty much
just need Texas College athletics and
then if in football or basketball you
want to travel all over knock yourself
out but
um if you're talking about uh playing a
men's soccer game there's no need for
Baylor to put their men's soccer team on
a plane to go play Central Florida and
Texas which is 90 minutes away to put
their men's soccer team on on a plane
and fly to Florida to play them they can
be on the same plane when you could just
have a little bus so I would probably
regionalize Northeast Mid-Atlantic you
know deep so whatever you do and uh
break it up that way and then have your
football and your men's basketball uh
leagues that work uh in in conjunction
to that the ACC reaching out apparently
to uh Stanford and Cal yeah is that real
nothing says Atlantic Coast I know uh
Dan like the The Fog coming in off the
San Francisco Bay
um
it's real uh because why not
if you're and so there's an example of
maybe you just add football but but
Stanford and Cal needs something for
their their Olympic programs because
they're those teams are are top of the
class National Championship caliber and
they need competition the the closest
they can get is the ACC uh it's real I
don't know if it happens
um you somehow have to come up with a
cost ability to send people but but
Stanford and Cal are in a world of of
trouble trying to find equal talent for
their their soccer their volleyball
their swimming programs that are are as
good as any in the country uh the
concept of putting someone flying 3 000
miles for every single Road game is uh
lunacy I mean look if you're going to
one of those schools Cal or Stanford you
are almost by definition academically
minded you the last thing you want to be
when you're at Stanford is not at
Stanford missing the classes being
exhausted flying back because you had a
I had a volleyball game at Virginia Tech
last night
um those things are just seem I mean
this is not College athletics in any
form why wouldn't Stanford just go
independent
they can but it'd be pretty much the
similar thing their problem is they'll
get
almost no football
television Revenue it works for Notre
Dame because NBC is willing to pay them
yeah and then they got an NBC deal
coming in two years that'll probably be
more they could fund their athletic
department off of football Stanford's
not gonna that people aren't going to
pay for Stanford home games the way they
pay for Notre Dame home games we're
talking to Dan Wetzel Yahoo sports
columnist
um trying to figure out it feels like if
there's another Domino or two it's uh
with Florida State and Clemson and I was
told you know the SEC may just block
this so the Big Ten doesn't get
into their footprint there with Florida
State and Clemson I don't know what
happens with the ACC I don't you know
there's contracts but we've seen those
contracts broken it feels like Florida
state is adamant that they're they're
out of there the question is when and
then what's the SEC do or what's the Big
Ten do feels like those are the only two
players here what do you think happens
with these schools there's definitely
one more round here the other being
Notre Dame does Notre Dame ever have to
join and the SEC and Big Ten will wage
uh no pun intended a holy war trying to
get Notre Dame to convince Notre Dame
they should join their league in the
other
um Clemson Florida State Miami North
Carolina is very appealing to these
leagues uh Virginia here's the thing I
just announced six schools that are all
very appealing they all play football
against each other there should be room
for a third uh League you know you still
have Duke bass Duke and Carolina
basketball I mean imagine a league
imagine a world where we know football
destroys the Carolina Duke basketball
rivalry now they could still play twice
a year and stuff but some of this stuff
just doesn't you know it it's it's hard
to it's hard to deal with
um right now the ACC is is stuck with
each other and Florida state is raising
a lot of noise but and they say we're
going to get out if they could get out
they'd be out uh they don't have a way
out uh they're they're not bluffing but
this deal runs through 2036 and it is uh
so even you know over the next few years
and I know this is hopelessly naive and
you can have me back on to Heckle me in
like two minutes when we've announced
Clemson and Florence native left but it
seems like they're stuck and so that's
where you're at I will say this the SEC
is quite happy with where they're at
they're adding Texas and Oklahoma they
have 16 teams they have they win all the
Championships they have an enormous
amount of money coming in their league
still makes sense it's still a southern
based big State School league uh pretty
much it's the Big Ten that's that's just
all over the map and and the Big Ten is
like a house that keeps adding on
additions but bringing in different
Architects so they brought in Rutgers in
Maryland they're on the east East Coast
for basic cable homes 10 years ago now
they're out west with four teams they
brought Nebraska in to be a National
Power and and when she helped push Ohio
State and Michigan they've had seven
straight losing Seasons the Big Ten one
is all over the map the SEC is very
purposeful it's basically worked
um it's going fine and they're kind of
looking back laughing and going we want
somebody we're going to go get them but
you are right at some point Clemson
Florida State Miami North Carolina is
again very very appealing because the
size of the market the academics and
then Notre Dame though it's going to be
that's going to be the next wave they
just released a poll yesterday
pre-season poll uh 11 of the 15. top 15
are in either the SEC or the new SEC or
the new Big Ten starting next year and
then there's Notre Dame and there's
three others so the the the the two
super conferences are either here or
essentially here
plus wait till March Madness when these
conferences dominate you know the number
of schools that get into March Madness
oh that they will dominate some but like
the big 12 and the Big East and Gonzaga
basketball is a different
thing and that's and that's why because
you can say look
um
Minnesota has uh you know 70 million
dollars in Revenue coming in every year
but Connecticut's two hours from New
York city so there's other things that
make this work the Big 12 will be the
best basketball conference not only they
have Baylor and Kansas and and I said
they just added Arizona and all these
things so basketball is its own thing
hockey this is why I'm saying hockey's
its own thing
let football be its own thing let
baseball be its own thing let let you
know women's field hockey be there's no
sense and we've seen this with Boston
College it's never made any sense that
Boston College sends their tennis team
to play Florida State when they could
get on a bus and ride down to Providence
College and have a nice nice match on on
Tuesday afternoon never gets back to
campus
but that would make sense Dan and
Collins college sports does not make
sense no one is it makes money you
should be in charge you should be in
charge exactly that's what I want to do
when I retire uh great to talk to you
Dan thanks for joining us always fun
thanks that's Dan Wetzel Yahoo sports
National comes he's always got some
ideas here on how to make things better
it's just I don't know if there's any
real think tank that they get together
and they go okay what would actually be
the would be better for College
athletics not my school individually but
you know the totality of College
athletics